and joining us now without further ado
is Congressman Steve King and we're
delighted he's joining us from Iowa I
believe congressman how are you good to
see you doing just fine right in my
living room Laura it's terrific chance
to be high tonight and and your
monologue next time you've been out in
my neighborhood before and I appreciated
that fantastic let's talk about the
president's plan the four pillars of it
were announced late yesterday it's a
change from a week ago where it was
800,000 daca recipients would have a
pathway eventually to citizenship moved
on from that to 1.8 million kept the
other elements basically in place
congressman an end to chain migration 25
billion for the border wall and security
which is good stuff and the visa lottery
system would be kind of replaced would
be used those 50,000 to end the family
and merit-based backlog of legal
immigrants who've been applying and
waiting for years and years tell us what
your biggest concern is with this and
could you ever support an amnesty that
would lead to a reduction in legal
immigration you know I haven't seen the
plan that would get me to support again
amnesty under any of these circumstances
but I do recognize the value of the
Goodlatte bill which now looks like this
proposal blocks and that but the numbers
are just stunning to see that President
Trump has proposed 1.8 that 11.8 million
amnesty to illegals and you know I'm
very familiar with his immigration
policy I actually I told him one day
that market-tested your immigration
policy in Iowa for 14 years and that's
the reason that he's President of the
United States today I think that this
will demoralize so very many of his
supporters and how do we get back now to
a place where we need to be with this
and by the way he had a mandate to end
daca a mandate for a wall a mandate to
end Jane migration and mandate a in the
visa lottery we can go on and on with
this and why they're matched up against
each other
negotiating against himself as very
troubling to me and I think that seeing
the Democrats turn against it the one
thing he's accomplishing is he's
convincing the American people of the
real truth which is Democrats don't care
about solving this problem they want
this problem to exploit it politically
and to bring more and more people into
the United States that'll be on their
side of the political ledger I mean I do
think he has exposed me no it's not the
plan I would want and I I'm the I'm for
the Goodlatte bill I think that would be
a great you know a great path forward
but let's listen to what Mercedes Lapps
said I should say before we play it we
invited any White House official onto
the show tonight we were told we were
gonna have one and then they pulled him
at the last minute so I want to hear
from the White House on this I'd like to
interview the President on this and you
know obviously he just came back tonight
but hi we hope to have someone on on
Monday but let's listen to what Mercedes
said from the White House earlier today
let's watch clearly it needs to be a
bipartisan bill if we would clearly have
a 60 votes with Republicans that would
support this it would be a lot easier we
are not in that Congress is not in that
position so this is why you need a
compromise on immigration but clearly
from the standpoint of the White House
it is clear as the president has said
time and time again there needs to be a
wall if there is no wall there is no
daca congressman your response it has to
get to 60 votes in the Senate Goodlatte
bill would be dead on arrival number of
senators told me that today would not
pass so what do you say well the best
part of that statement is no wall No
Deal we must have the wall the most
important reason we need to have the
wall is because walls don't have
prosecutorial discretion even a
subsequent president will have a hard
time tearing down you get the wall on
the deal you end chain migration chain
migration is 400,000 people a year so in
four years five years you would have
more than the 1.8 million amnesty of new
family based migration that's gone so in
five years you would already you would
already swamp that 1.8 number
exceed it and the cuts would still keep
coming so I don't see that you're gonna
get a cut in legal family chain
migration without some sort of amnesty
maybe not this big but without some sort
of amnesty and I just don't see it
well here at Laurel here's what this
establishes though if the president
serves up 1.8 million people for an
amnesty in exchange for 25 billion
dollars for a wall and then reduces the
numbers of the chain migration that come
in that's the end of his enforcement
that he's going to get in his in his
administration unless we come up with
another amnesty to serve it up because
he will have established that precedent
and by the way this is a sacrifice of
the rule of law that says in your
lifetime were in mind we will never see
the respect for the rule of law restored
again and that's what I've been working
at since 1986 when this mistake was made
then by Ronald Reagan lessons they're in
front of us it's the same debates and
it's a debate today is the same as it
was in 86 it hasn't changed now a rule
of law has got to be respected I
completely agree with you on that let's
just very quickly we're almost out of
time this is what some of the left-wing
advocates have said today in response to
1.8 million listen to this the white
house yeah the White House released a
hateful xenophobic immigration proposal
the ACLU The Huffington Post writer it's
a little more than a racist ransom note
from a group of nativist America's voice
they think they're offering up a
spoonful of sugar they can get Congress
and the American people to swallow the
bitter medicine of radical nativism
United We Dream says let's call this
proposal what it is a white supremacist
ransom note now come on the left is so
over Oh over the top in the response
Trump has exposed them as fanatics and I
my listeners are enraged I can tell you
that congressman they they are just they
can't even believe what they're hearing
but the practical understanding of all
this is you don't have 60 Steve Kings in
the Senate you don't have 60 Steve
King's we're gonna vote for cloture on
an immigration proposal it's just not
going to happen it's I wish we did I
wish we had work together believed in
the rule of law that's I looked around
here a week ago Laura and
again I had a hard time finding anybody
now that Coalition is growing so thanks
a lot for doing this tonight I
appreciate it all right we appreciate it
and by the way congressman we could be
on the verge of a stunning game-changer
in the Russia investigation but the
forces aligned against President Trump
are fighting back